okay we have two voicemails for you
today this is an example of there are
callers to the show who will call
multiple times a day sometimes for weeks
months or even years with the exact same
sort of fixation this particular example
is one about sjw's okay so this is just
an example of how somebody gets totally
obsessed with the topic this is someone
who's been calling for weeks almost
every day about sjws last night they
left two voicemails in a row about sjw's
let's take a listen to the first one hey
David this is Kevin from Nebraska and I
just wanted to know why social justice
warriors and liberals are never happy
because all they do is fill out their
gender politics and make everything
about them they have little to no like
version of Southworth and they try to
make everyone see things their way when
a small minority of people only agree
with them and they use the media to
bully and get people fired okay thank
you so totally incoherent and then
immediately called the right back with
another voicemail about sjw's hey David
this is Kevin from Nebraska and I just
wanted to one I was wondering about what
you thought with sjw's and a lot of
people on the left side
pushing their political agendas and
social order agendas on movies and the
movies doing bad like the lady
Ghostbusters movie and the upcoming
Captain Marvel movie why not just focus
on making movies good rather than
pushing an agenda that no one wants
everyone wants to have fun and not think
of politics just wanted to give my two
cents on that thank you yeah so listen I
know that some people are gonna hear
this and they're gonna write in and say
they're gonna actually be mad at me for
playing these and they'll say David this
is clearly an autistic person and you're
sort of making fun of them by even
playing these voicemails but I don't
know that it sounds like an adult who's
calling in to the show so if that's what
your email is going to be then you know
let's let's skip that how do people get
so obsessed and fixated with topics
where the this is just two of a whole
bunch of voicemails probably a dozen or
so over the last week where they're just
calling a show over and over and over
again five minutes apart the calls are
coming in almost identical incoherent
not making any sense but so sure that
sjw's so-called are bad I don't really
get it so if somebody wants to explain
this to me in some way other than just
this is an autistic person and we
shouldn't make fun of them I would love
to hear from you because that are just I
just thought I'd never met anyone in my
life who would do something like this so
I'm I want to hear from you what is it
that's going on here how does someone
get so obsessed is it the internet red
pilling is it something going on in
people's lives what is it that has led
to of folks like this and these
obsessions in American society on
today's bonus show we will hear Pat's
karaoke story which a lot of people are
very very curious about we will have for
you and
update to the texting suicide case of
Michelle Carter and I also have very bad
news
for the Mars one are related to the Mars
one project to go to Mars on a one-way
trip all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show the two ways to get
access to the bonus show are become a
member at wwe.com or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
thanks for watching thanks for listening
I will speak to you then